to rock and roll baby it's Friday and
your leader
Bhupesh maximus is here to take the lead
welcome my super troopers today we have
for you a super entertainer a super
exciting episode of the h3 podcast fresh
as it gets filmed this morning this
afternoon and brought to you steaming
hot and fresh the same day for your
enjoyment thank you to audible for
sponsoring this episode and thank you to
Eva Klein for being a wonderful care of
wonderful mom
excellent co-host and I mean truly Oh
whooping what man could ask for a better
wife and partner in life I thank you it
for that so thank you very much I want
to thank Dan the producer who dares to
care about a show this Thanksgiving I
don't know I just send them I'm just
following my spirit takes my gratitude
okay I want to thank Dan the producer
who cares on a level that is well he
should care that much because it is a
job and we do pay him fair I think a
fair wage to care that level but
regardless of the of the compensation he
does care he's got a great personality
and boy do we love to have him that's
true thanks man was that not lukewarm
lukewarm I mean was it good or did it
not no no good we do average Dan we
appreciate that in there in problem with
it starts to sound like you're kidding
I'm not kidding I want I want I wish I
could send ongoing problem so we have to
address ok well this part I'm definitely
not I definitely am not kidding when I
say Ian the intern he is there there he
is and we love him for being there don't
we and Zach of course who could forget
who could forget whenever the audio
levels are off blame this
we love you Zack we're gonna be in guys
let's get into the show for Christ's
sake we've got you didn't thank Allah o
Allah or you know Allah ya Yahweh Yahweh
Yahweh see Allah's the is the Muslim God
God
I'm just minions Yahweh is the Jewish
God I don't care about what I'm thinking
Jesus or we'll be thanking God we're
taking it we're trick question you're
both the same thing we are thinking the
Supreme Being that put us all here
together Wow and this blessed Friday wow
thank you so the one true and only God
whether you are a Muslim a Christian a
Jew that's right this one God is like
eight you could call me whatever you
want about it exactly to meet it's the
regula and we serve it every day Roz
again so everyone go down alright let's
we have had a fascination with scooter
scooter madness scooter people have way
too much confidence they have no
consideration of other people on the
road on the streets they have completely
lost their mind and they're out of
control
there's something that happens when you
sit on a scooter that it's like a brain
infection where it's like it's almost
like a mental illness and I'm not making
I'm just saying when you sit on a
scooter something in your brain clicks
and you're like oh the world is in my
way it's what happens to spite him and
when he got bit by the spider hmm gives
you get the scooter power scooter powers
well scooter powers unfortunately have
limits and we've seen those limits time
and time again I've got a bunch of new
scooter content man the one I really
wanted to show you guys is actually we
decided not to but I'll describe it to
you it's this guy in Korea he misses the
elevator because somebody I guess did
leave it open firm and obviously is on
the scooter the whole world needs to
cooperate with his demands so here's the
crazy part you see the elevator lowering
so the guy on the scooter knew that
elevator had already dipped out so he
backs up rams the elevator full speed
and you see him lurch forward backs up a
second time Rams a full sleeve to the
door flips back the elevator door flips
back exposing the shaft and at that
point you're like whoa dude that was
close and you would think that he would
at that point be like well that was a
close call
he so he backs he goes back a third time
slams that he floors this scooter pedal
he's going 15 miles per my 50 miles per
hour flooring it slams it again
tge and he goes slips under the elevator
shaft and the funny thing and I'm sad to
say it it is funny that he's holding on
he never lets go that handles like he
still thinks he's in control of the
scooter as he slips under the elevator
door and you can see him just you know
he's holding like he's still got his
foot on the gas all the way and he just
falls down the shaft and then the door
flips back behind him hmm and nothing
and he disappeared and he literally fell
down an elevator shaft yeah we thought
it might be too much to show but I mean
it's a it is so the guy you know I mean
he probably suffered a terrible fate but
truthfully after three times of trying
to enter an empty elevator shaft the
second time it almost flipping I don't
know what else I don't know how much
sympathy I have for a man who was prone
to tur insanity he had one goal and he
was gonna get it he was getting in that
[ __ ] elevator that [ __ ] did not open
the door I wonder if he just flopped on
the top of that elevator ultimate
revenge
hmm but but anyway
we don't have to watch that one but I
have plenty that we will watch let's
start here that would be a scooter lady
in a convenience store you know
everyone's here she had to enter here
she comes
get off get out of my way she's already
like out of control and you see how that
guy moved that's how he jumped out of
the way because he's like dude
there was a lady she's like dude if I
don't move it I'm losing it and and then
here she comes through the aisle just
knocked over a whole case the whole
display got knocked over and I'm
assuming that happened because somebody
didn't open the door for her or
something so that's I mean we're just
getting started here on scooter scooter
mania here folks it's good our nation
scooter Naish I gotta get me a scooter
look at this crazy guy
this isn't Australia this crazy mother
is on the freeway and he tells the part
of [ __ ] off to look at this scooter
nation Oh watch this [ __ ]
imagine getting on the freeway and a
scooter it's gonna get into the left
lane - yeah he's gonna get into this
fast lane oh oh they drive on the wrong
side of the road right right it is the
wrong side maybe you're on the freeway
you're not supposed to be on the freeway
I love that it did [ __ ] off mate -
Chileans are so great [ __ ] off me you're
on the freeway mate it's like like it's
so dangerous and scary but they still
talk the same you're on the freeway
might [ __ ] off Guardian he's calling the
police and the police come up and show
up and it goes [ __ ] ah mate
and the police go you're on the freeway
you're on the freeway mate yeah [ __ ] off
there's some bloke on the freeway and a
scooter yeah yeah does this homie do
this on the regular do you think would
you pick Australian accent if you could
pick one to have it I do love ya it's
near the top for me yeah I think so I
just love it I love the Vinaya fire that
are your dad's good daddy your dad's
that might be a New Zealand thing but
radiya dad's right
even the dispatcher is laughing yeah I
just love they just seem to have a great
denim they got a great sense of humor as
a people and you're on the freeway mate
oh he's crossing is crazy why did he get
into the lane oh my god his trucks so
this is I am by this is not the first
time this dude has done this may you're
on the freeway yeah yeah [ __ ] off he's a
man brown jacket
yeah description yeah you can't miss him
mate
he's on a scooter on the freeway they
actually show up really fast I was
impressed with the Australian police
responding he's really he's travelling
quite a distance do you know how many
guys do you have on that thing there's a
battery electric yeah I can't imagine it
goes for that long
look at that cop is like alright good
excuse me that you're on the freeway
so good mm-hmm yeah that guy definitely
was a good Samaritan yeah let me go back
to the conference that epic
confrontation that definitely was my
favorite part
did they already have a epic
confrontation no not yet
it's right after this yeah this is a
guys buckle up buckle up in those
scooter sees we're going 18 kilometers
an hour maybe you're on the freeway
you're not supposed to be on the freeway
I love his outfit no yeah and he's got a
cane in back that's my favorite outfit
for an old guy just classic as it gets
like a brown kind of cardigan and then
Adidas tracksuit pants yeah and then
you've got like the paper yeah it's a
tannic anus yeah yeah move over mate
you're on the freeway [ __ ] I've got
these guys they're so so I mean scooter
mania is Chris intercontinental
it crosses boundaries this was us oh
this was a short you this was a fan
submission Dan yeah somebody emailed
this to me oh my god yo you're gonna
love this
you're getting a lot of scooter
submissions people coming I mean I want
to exhaust the the pool you know you saw
this and in preparation for today
yeah exam because did that hit her so
hard she's a heavy lady that it lifted
her front wheels back [ __ ] so like that
was a pretty fun in fact you're going
quick and she didn't see that just
continues on that's the SCOOTER beauty
let's go let's slow down here I don't
want to miss a frame I think I finally
know what to get you for your birthday
[Music]
yeah you know what happened because
Sheena okay she snapped her face on this
thing and she kept her hand on the gas
so the wheel popped up let's see what
she refused to take your damn hand off
the gas like all these scooter people
refuse to slow down Frank doesn't even
seem hurt yeah you gonna buy me a
mobility scooter yeah you know somebody
raised a good point that our hundred
sure challenged
I was that scooter guy yeah I was
channeling scooter oh this was so
fantastic I got a what sorry everyone
brag do they cost a couple couple towie
probably yeah maybe maybe upwards ten
thousand for a really premium [ __ ] do
you need like a licen permit [ __ ] no
dude no way you need a permit for that
[ __ ]
[Music]
dude oh I mean that must have been quite
an impact cuz it lifted her lifted the
whole scooter up looks like they're
between 800 and 3,000 that's what I'm
saying yeah it's like third for the
premium [ __ ] you know what I should that
would be that it's the most epic prop
ever here you look at mobility live I'm
already doing stuff oh my god that would
be so fun
oh that would be so fun the crews around
the neighborhood in a mobility scooter
did I love it everyone would know me man
so well finally I have what is possibly
the most famous scooter what's the word
vigilante mobility meri is her name and
she has a YouTube channel that was quite
famous quite notorious she would film
herself cruising around in public on her
scooter and recording and what her
opinion was evidence of people
mistreating her as a handicapped lady
but what an actuality was her being a
scooter person and so this is 12 minutes
long and I'm like whoa whoa this is a
best-of Curcio or does she post them you
know her she has a YouTube channel Wow
and so I quickly realized that it's all
gold and I'm telling you let's just
watch it and we can turn it off when
we're over it but it's all gold I mean
watch this
oh so good excuse me excuse me it's just
a dude yeah this is my er look look
where it is this is the 405 South yeah I
think she lives in Santa Monica or
something oh it's just a dude with the
bike who's making way for her across the
street
he literally couldn't get out of the way
more think so care yet
Mary gets attacked by ferocious
man-eating dogs do tiny like five pound
cutie pies the sweetest little dog with
scars from dogs it's Halloween it's this
sweet is that true by the way I guess
you have your dogs on a leash anywhere
anytime I mean I don't know about the
whole of United States but I'm pretty
sure you can't speak the whole of united
most place yeah I guess so but these are
like tiny tiny cute I mean this building
on this building goes shredder shredder
loves to like say hi to everyone so
there was a lady and he jumped at her
trying to say hi hmm and she was like
you need to have him on a leash was she
on a scooter nope
I guess she's covered in scars from dogs
and she's just constantly mean by the
way mauled by dogs especially a dog
that's it but watch how she bones out at
the end of the conflict Jake all right
well see ya face Mountain
here's another ferocious dog this woman
is probably his head for something she's
well behind her I'm sure she can hear
her does she not have a bell or
something
it's something about being on a scooter
down telling him oh did you flip her off
she there flipped her offer waved it her
I
I have to wonder it wait that's gone she
probably knows her yeah it's probably
unknown Oh personality in this new that
kind of changed perspective though I got
a flip off it's true although she this I
wouldn't be surprised if this woman
tried to like get her dog euthanized by
the city or something yeah and she's
like alright I'm not moving out of the
way yes she definitely flipped her off
oh that's serious beef this is pretty
epic she's knocking on her to by
standards now she stops in a crosswalk
don't argue with pedestrians about it
alright good she's long gone and
mobilities I could you see what I'm
saying I could watch this whole thing
easily yeah each one of these is a high
light weight this there's a there's a
finale to this one that's particularly
oh it has an oh yeah dude look how fast
oh she caught up oh man this is serious
beef
this lady won't let me go pastor oh my
god she won't just move over for a
minute what I love how she involves
everyone in her know yo this [ __ ] is
crazy well she clearly knows what to do
she's got a run right there on this is
great this is this is better than both
most movies I've watched this is the
most exciting thing on television right
now I mean I have to know what happened
with twins yeah because it's like it's
quite insane what the other ladies doing
it this yeah this is pretty [ __ ] up
even if she did try to get your dog you
that hates my the city just let her pass
this is some real vindictive [ __ ] and
you can only imagine her screaming at
her this whole time excuse me dan this
is something else where's this what part
of town is this I like I said I think
it's like Santa Monica uh yeah jenny is
full somewhere on the way on the west
side I can't get close to your dog
and you're going on YouTube that's true
so they definitely have previous beat
yeah hold on let me let me examine three
that's the best part just call I'm sorry
I would just want to hear what they said
again now's your chance
oh she can't get close to the dog lady
you gotta you gotta move along I do feel
like she probably called the police on
the dog and something here something
stupid oh is it gonna happen in my dream
what another flip up okay yeah this
lady's crazier than this is the crazy
lady in the video that lady's up oh my
god whoa I didn't expect that now all of
a sudden I mean maybe there is scooter
discrimination yeah feeling some
sympathy for Mary here yeah when I first
saw her throw up that middle finger I
was like oh the lady doesn't here right
huh I have to assume that they have
history oh they do
she said that yeah I've met you before
right but regardless I mean you're not
even on a scooter you can't act like
that off a scooter
Wow I mean yeah
but do you see what I'm saying like I'm
I'll keep watching us the whole a
podcast would just be more
no even would you want a three will or
four wheel scooter you browsing Amazon
it
well three wheel doesn't sound stable at
all I Who am I gonna run over with more
you I think no well they're the same
price I went for was the preference
what's the point of having three wheels
if it's the same price it's like she
said it's an element of danger man yeah
you can hit turns harder that's how it's
good or nice you are you know I want
four wheels cuz I need I need balance I
need I need weight and I need balance
okay
I'll add that to the factors
I want the craziest scooter you can find
and I'll put spikes on the front of it
like I could take it to West Coast
costumes that would be so epic good
she's in the bike lane now man that's
pretty
he's in the bike lane there's a bus on
the right she's crossing the
intersection I'm scared for her right
now so a car passed on her right and
pulled into Taco Bell and now she's
chasing him down almost took out a
runner to him wait she's going to the
drive-through I think she's going after
him was that a dangerous movement I did
I mean he knew he was going inside the
car yes let me let me describe to our
audio listeners so she was crossing the
street and he passed on her right but he
went to the driveway so I think it was
fine but she was so spooked that she
followed him into the talk about he's in
the driveway ordering and she's pulled
up behind him in the driveway a talk
about he's trying to order on the
intercom and she's yelling that's good
people get it hard I mean she's
definitely stubborn like but people are
really aggressive I mean this guy is
coming out hard but on the other hand
he's like look but she's probably an
elderly lady on a scooter would you yell
it I would be like yeah I mean right no
no I wouldn't course not and why was she
she backed up we're going in Reverse
with my kids here go away
Oh doing you and they're alive you
almost killed me know is right she was
in the middle of the street yeah it's
not a bike oh my god how can so much
golden content be generated from one
person yeah like I swear to god these
are all bestsellers I always find that
interesting defense and I've seen it
before when a parent comes out acting
crazy and cursing and goes I've got my
kids here
it's like isn't that why he should be
chilled out get the [ __ ] out of my face
I'll cut my kids here it's like no so
you can get 9 miles and gonna charge 9
miles on a charge how far does that
forward point 25 speed well-disposed
that 4.25 is the top speed 4.25 miles
per hour
no no see you're looking at [ __ ] cuz
I see her these people going like 15
miles for an hour okay
that's garbage okay he needs one he can
take on the freeway okay I need one that
goes at like I mean I'm looking for one
that goes 15 at least okay 4 miles per
hour how close that get out here you I
thought you loved me that you okay let's
check out that $3,000 one yeah what the
hell are you looking at you can find me
some what was that 1-800
worth that to you so this one top speed
eight nine miles per hour
see you're not you come out this seat
just link to your 15 or the seat is 22
inch wide well you're feeling that I
don't know take a measurement I don't
know why my ass is these days either you
keep doing research on my watch this 15
miles per hour sounds good though
under a bridge here she's under a bridge
in LA a lot of Hawaii people and Epps
fit in LA and so someone has a tent
pitch with all their belongings and the
sidewalk is blocked although she has a
point doesn't she I mean you you really
should not be blocking sidewalk yeah I
mean there are mobility laws for
handicapped people for a reason and I
think she has a valid point in this case
you know you should check out the after
this the scooter in this corn the
dancing okay great this is just the
scooter episode
but I mean I kind of do agree like this
is totally out of control there you have
to leave space for people to cross but
it's more you think this people are
choosing anything right now
like I understand they're homeless but
still like what is she doing there she's
she's on the scooter she's travels by
scooter on the way to Whole Foods but I
love what a tragedy it she was crying
yeah it sounds like
look as a homeless person you definitely
want to not be violating the law because
you know if you're trying to live and
not disrupt the flow of society then
regard it doesn't matter what their
situation is they can't block the whole
sidewalk hey people on scooters need to
be able to travel bikes need to be able
to travel people on foot need to be able
to travel you're saying it's okay that
he's walking the entire sidewalk no it's
not okay
but I doubt these people anything is
okay in their life you know what I mean
it's like fine I get it you're they're
homeless they probably yeah okay but
still I'm sympathizing with with scooter
marry this looks like a man Larry yeah
oh this is like think about there's lots
of places in LA where you're the
sidewalk goes under the freeway this is
like you're traveling like between the
neighborhood it's not well maybe that's
true it's going too far she's gone too
[Laughter]
only got like one more mile left on
their battery she's gonna get stuck okay
just check out that scooter
oh you sent me you want me to look at a
scooter yeah cuz it's got a
demonstration video let me finish this
saga and all open that up I mean just
this clip cuz I want to see how she
takes him out or marry almost gets it
you don't want to watch this first we're
at the 30-minute mark
this is the scooter up oh it's dark
she's on the scooter at night okay I
wonder if she's got lights on it gotta
stay home I bet you she doesn't have
lights on it or anything
you remember how in Israel people like
go full-speed on the sidewalk can you
imagine her dealing with that oh my god
I'm on the edge of my seat
oh yes I mean let me go back I got it
here if you see you totally couldn't see
him coming well there's no light she's
not she doesn't have lights gonna make
any difference
well better it hits me that hits you
she's like well there you go see someone
saying someone who looks like you but
she doesn't have like time she's not
following this good of rules gonna be I
would have dark oh oh oh this is my
favorite this is the first one I ever
saw this dude on escape
I'm not sure yet how they're gonna
interact is that a corner
I should do it on a skateboard waiting
across the street
it's not until she crosses that the
incident happens
she's upset I don't know why okay
skateboarders out of frame so then I'm
his problem yeah I think there's a long
gap here you can fast-forward well they
really included her just waiting idle
yeah well I'm here for every single
moment of it and I'm in for the long
stretch I think she's waiting for her to
switch is that right then yeah they got
they they did us the courtesy of her
waiting at this red light yes
like kinda bike showed up okay oh she
bad wasn't she backed up for him and
said sorry
I mean pretty needy thoughtful me like
an episode of the handmade still you can
thinking something's gonna happen
alright they could have cut this I mean
really okay it's green we got a green
light
there we go she's moving
he's in the street season finale
white he's halfway across there's some
o'clock in this someone blocking the
curb with a wheelchair there's plenty of
soot so again once again I feel like it
takes two to tango yeah like she is
obviously obnoxious and roasts people
wrong but so first person well clearly
she is enough space yes but this lady is
intentionally because she's here to buy
by mobility marry she could easily just
take another step in the other direction
but she's not just despite her but but
she's on the street right now so I think
this lady is just wanting her to get off
the street first and then they'll figure
it out you know I mean what's the finger
out she's obviously just because she's
standing in the direction she wants to
go I guess oh I think she just wants to
go straight you look here I don't think
so no she does she just wants to go
straight she's not even turning right
wash it let's keep watching
[Music]
look at her finger I need to get out of
the street
I can't until you move out of just
that's a handicap without you I can't go
over the curb right there oh my god
you can't move another couple vases
oh there's someone in the wheelchair no
see she made it perfectly when she went
straight oh my god scooter boy that was
fun I don't know what can top all that
but I'm definitely willing to see what
else is out there
so Allah sent me a scooter she's got our
eyes on a birthday present for me it's
called progress mobility comm $3,000 I
cannot believe you can get in the door
for $3,000 Oh check out this video okay
Emily of scooters introducing that's all
I mean that's all I saw I love this shot
you poor will eat they didn't even add a
full screen option they're like these
old [ __ ] don't know here I'm gonna zoom
look at those this look badass those are
like little Vespa yeah yeah
we should get till he wheels we know a
new member to the e wheels families
introducing our new food wheel aw 72 he
wheels is a trendsetter when it comes to
offering an mobility scooter that has
style speed quality and at a price that
anyone can afford I mean let's face it
our scooters are not like the ones that
grandma used to put around on our W 72
powerful 700 watt motor enables this
scooter to reach speed 50 miles per hour
that's what I'm talkin about
whoops with the speed rheostat I need to
her to be able to hurt people you know
in mile-per-hour which is nice if you're
in a crowded space
oh that's cool the maximum weight up
nobody ever put that down so it's always
that 15 I trust my own leg when it comes
to school so 20 bucks
not bad what color do you want me Oh
tell me to check if there is like a
scooter for
- for talking to me sorry
get out of my life do you want me to
check if there's a scooter for a family
are you like a tandem scooter okay on
your own in this mission you want to
write tandem with me and Theodore I
don't know if that kind of defeats the
point that kind of reduces your mobility
on a mobility scooter I think we ought
to have our own okay you know cuz
frankly either you just slow me down
mmm-hmm what are we haven't we had 30
minutes yeah break time well that was a
lot of fun on this epic Friday this most
epic of Fridays it's me a lot of fans
very happy we watched mobility marry Tim
it was submitted like 30 times he's a
legend yes she really is a legend yeah
and I'm and I'm gonna say she's not
always wrong but he is always Oh a
little bit much so that being said guys
we will be right back right right right
back after this quick commercial break
do not go anywhere
books is a beautiful thing it's the
spark of life that gives us knowledge
creativity and entertainment books is a
delight it's magic Carl Sagan once said
books is the closest thing to magic we
can achieve as humanity it's one dead
person speaking through you to you
through the pages of a book that's why I
love audible because audible translates
that magic into things that you can
listen to it's amazing and also you can
do it but previously you had to choose
were you reading or were you doing other
things with audible that choice is made
moot because I can exercise I can game I
can drive I can babysit I can do pretty
much just about anything and enrich my
life while listening to audiobooks it
makes us smarter connect it makes us
better partners parents it's inspiring
voices compel stories opening listeners
to new experiences and ways of thinking
and guess what
there's no better place to listen than
audible audible members choose three
titles every month one audiobook plus
two audible originals that you can't
hear anywhere else just go to AUD IBL
e.com slash h3 podcast or text h3
podcast - 500 500 and browse their
unmatched selection of audio content now
here I want to recommend to you guys
it's chapter 2 is about to hit movie
theaters right freaking now and you are
not and if if you have the opportunity
to get this epic masterpiece on your
audiobook it will give you chills spills
spooks and more the narrator Steven
Weber is a genius he's got all the moves
he creates this beautiful atmosphere and
you're not gonna want to miss this part
- 28 years later they come back to the
town because kids are missing again this
is the book make sure the lights are on
think as spooky as it gets
okay so now here also gets even better
start listening with a 30 day trial in
your first audiobook plus two audible
originals for free when you go to
audible.com slash Ashley podcast for
free yes I said free 30-day trial or tax
h3p OD c AST a free podcast text HD
podcast to 500 500
and because we have one sponsor today
and I am likely running to the bathroom
as fast as I can to pee I would like to
take this time to say hey how are you
nice to have you here we appreciate
everyone coming out here take an
opportunity to listen to last week's
episode it was hamstrung by YouTube
because we talked about naughty topics
and it got suppressed I think it's a
great episode I think we talk about
really important things but I think it's
a shame that certain topics I can't even
say the name that guys like Volta more
on YouTube I can't even say his name
apparently without getting this rating
that suppresses the views so if you got
a time this weekend check out last
week's episode as well and while you're
at it this hot spicy shirt which I love
well my favorite shirts we've ever made
it's so soft and breathable and it's
just great teddy fresh calm you know
what time it is Teddy fresh calm you
know what time it is Dan how long's this
been oh it's been a minute a minute so
what do you think we probably have
enough time now I'm probably just
running back into the office about to
sit down now so with that let's get back
into the show well I had a lot of fun
I was just meaning you were just
discussing that we need to make an intro
for the podcast where we roll up on
scooters or some [ __ ]
or maybe like Dan's in the way and I
like bump into him yeah we talked last
episode about this fish cannon okay now
I expressed a lot of cynicism and and
and let me just say that I was being you
know over-the-top I didn't really I
wasn't as cynical as I made it out to
believe I caught people you know it's
real okay I accept that it's a real
thing I just think it's a funny way to
spend your time here on this planet
earth as a human being it's to make a
fish can developing right yeah okay and
to all the biology's out there who
they're all the all the apparent
ecologist
there you know everyone who's just like
of course a salmon cannon is a thing
Ethan the fish are extremely intense is
like all right yeah it's like all right
dude all of a sudden you guys care when
I'm wrong about something mm-hmm all the
sudden 100% of our viewers are
ecologists and know about fish cannons
did seem that way in the comments
section it did seem that way you said
yeah that's what I yeah exactly you know
what you you you were just playing it up
I was playing it I mean people are
people are gonna believe me now but I
was playing it up for comedic sake I
mean that's what I figured I don't have
that big of a problem believing it's
real I just thought it was a funny thing
you know what I mean
so to all the geniuses and PhDs out
there I have this to show you and
supportive of the cannon being real of
which I'm only still 90% sure you know
but here apparently these [ __ ]
restocking trout lake trout and Utah by
aircraft how are these [ __ ] so I was
like man how they survive that impact
into the lake these guys are just being
dropped out of airplane you know and
apparently that's fine
is that crazy surely like half of those
[ __ ] died don't think they're just
being dumped by air why are we so
fragile I want to be dumped by airplane
survive that [ __ ] these fish have no
problem being dropped from outer space
until [ __ ] Lake going like 200 miles
an hour look at him just getting tossed
out of that [ __ ] like a dirty wet fart
and that's look like that damn I was
trying to think how to describe it
yeah well I'm I did major in poetry in
high school so yeah I mean it's
captivating but both captivating and
shocking what's going on here they fish
out the the trout and then they restock
it this is why we needed the salmon
cannon if this is the alternative I can
see why this one guy in an upgrade
yo so these were the lucky ones and then
the plane takes off like goes higher up
and you can see there's one son of a gun
you'll see they're all pretty much out
and then just one is like I I'm [ __ ]
see that last one yeah I don't know I
don't like anyway so I thought that was
fascinating yeah
oh here you go waited till the last
second yeah that guy's [ __ ] he was the
pilot coming on reddit well in short I
still AM only I would say in fairness
seventy-five percent certain that the
cannon
yeah I'm going down now I want to give
an update that I got my citizenship
interview scheduled for next month now
I'm studying for the civics test and
Wyoming it's not on the civics test I
just started studying don't Cheyenne put
me on the spot right now am i right uh
wait you don't know don't what that or
eautiful is oh no I think it's Cheyenne
it Cheyenne good nice you see look at
you you are an American citizen Porsche
that's the Cayenne so don't don't let
the the customs see this why that's very
American of me to know the name of the
car very true go ahead so I
I am starting to study and then when I
feel ready we're gonna do the test on
the podcast 18 is gonna test me and
that's it I think you're gonna nail it
you're already getting close I got the
first 15 dollars out of 100 question
good though I mean we just started like
tell me this what are the what are the
three words in the Constitution that way
to people
mm-hmm why what what were what was the
civil war fought for um there's three
reasons yes
name one reason the Civil War was fought
there's three reasons that they list
there's one obvious one and race so you
keep saying and racism I go worse it was
worse right slaver yeah it's like racism
but way worse yes yeah slavery state
rights and to keep the Union together to
end slavery that would be crazy [ __ ] you
did Civil War
okay no no I gotta study none now's not
the time
yeah I just want to throw one more eye
oh oh yeah what's the capital of the
United States Washington DC and what's
the name of a state that borders Canada
Washington State there you go that's a
new one that yellow yeah I mean look
there's some are trickier than oh yeah
for sure but I'm excited you're gonna go
in there and they're gonna give you a
little American flag when you come out
and you're gonna be a citizen that's and
you're gonna get to vote in the 2020
election you may be even able to vote
fur really good like a little flag I
think they give you a little American
flag I mean whenever I see pic people of
pictures of people coming out after it
they have like an American flag so I'm
assuming they hand it to him no I'm
excited I mean I don't think they're all
bringing you know it's funny we have an
attorney whose hand helping us with it
and she one of the guidelines was dress
appropriately when you go on your
interview
do not wear American print shirts and
pants well was that I didn't read that I
remember reading that though to like not
go dress I can't wear my guy fieri had
yeah I mean that is a little over the
top but I mean why why not you know I
feel like you're trying too hard yeah I
think you're supposed to like look like
a respectable citizen is the best look
because also you have to take an English
less so you have to be able to speak
English pretty well to become a citizen
which of course is a selec YouTube there
was a huge development in the world of
YouTube epic epic epic victory in the
world of YouTube
huge this is amazing news so this is
something that I knew was in the works
but I didn't know when it was gonna
happen
Team YouTube look at the amount of likes
people are people are supporting it
120,000 likes they said new today a
policy preventing copyright owners for
making money on manual claims for short
song clips example 5 second of a song
unintentional audio examples music from
passing cars claimants can still block
monetization or the video it's
self but timestamps will help you edit
out in the claim even if they do do that
I feel like I had to supplement theirs
because I don't think they did a great
job of explaining it I was gonna say
they're doing better though oh yeah
they're doing much better like this no
you hate this too it makes sense before
they would just like come up with
statements that would just leaves you
leave you with many questions and I
don't know we got emojis now yeah I'm so
I wouldn't say I like the drumroll emoji
table was really cool but I said you
know for clarity this basically makes it
so that they can no longer make money on
brief matches and so the point of this
change is to remove the financial
incentive of these parasitic claim farms
like we've discovered that there's
companies that work that are third
parties that have just hoards people in
rooms watching YouTube videos all day
looking for any reason any excuse it has
nothing to do with fair use or good
faith it's literally just grabbing free
money from people that actually deserve
it and so what they're doing is removing
the financial incentive so if one of
these claim farms goes and finds for
example mr. beast humming the tune of a
song for five seconds they're like okay
you can claim the video you can block
the video well claim means that you
basically saying okay you you own
something that's copyrighted here so
they can claim the video still they
can't and you can block it you can claim
and track it but you cannot monetize it
that's what they change you so they
removing that option and thereby
removing the sense of altogether because
99% of time when you have a video that's
claimed it's they just want to earn
money on you exactly the setting they
choose is monetized no restrictions on
viewing
we just want the money no restrictions
no eye tracking no anything we just want
the free money ninety-nine percent of
the time and so YouTube in this really
brilliant play and let me tell you this
this play will not come without
challenges from these huge licence
holders UMG these behemoths a lot of
people are gonna be losing a lot of
money from this decision by YouTube and
I wouldn't be surprised in fact I be
surprised if there weren't some big
legal challenges court filings lawsuits
that comes youtube's way so I want to
appreciate the gravity of the situation
that YouTube is making a huge play at at
the risk of their own you know legal
status to the benefit of creators
so again YouTube's not very good at
Tooting their own horn so I want to help
them explain what a big deal this is
they're gonna they are going to this is
going to cost them mm-hmm a lot of good
faith and they're probably gonna get
sued by huge [ __ ] companies but there
you go I think you know they're standing
up and clearly I mean clearly people
saying well glad it you did it but what
it takes long I think this is something
that a lot of they've had a lot of
lawyers if a lot of people building the
case laying the groundwork you need to
have a solid case you can get pretty
like great to link when does it apply
and when doesn't they didn't say
specifically they just gave examples so
yeah the specific rules I'm sure are
they said in their longer description
that it's still like you gotta treat it
as you're responsible there's anything
that's not yours you know yeah
they can't 100% guarantee you anything
right right
right exactly and so they say this is an
important step with more to come towards
a better copyright system for creators
so yeah this is a huge step and like I
saying I think they must have had
lawyers laying the groundwork analyzing
looking for precedent looking for legal
arguments to make this move because you
got to be 100% ready for the legal
challenges that are never ibly gonna
come your way and they got to make sure
they've got a strong argument in case
and because you guys got to understand
there are laws that YouTube has to abide
by there are legal precedents that if
they don't abide by it the DMCA
like then they're the system in which we
enjoy is just simply not possible
YouTube cannot exist because they have
this treaty this you know it's like a
diplomatic agreement in a war they go
okay you can exist we recognize your
sovereignty as a website but we have to
have the right to steal whatever anytime
anything whatever cannot they don't want
the rights infringed at all so this is
YouTube's putting a line in the sand
shots are been fired you know what I
mean I mean this is really this is a big
thing here so so can I ask just so I
understand it correctly you they're
still you know say you have like a five
second clip of a song in a video that
they can still block your video yes yes
right but they just can't get any money
exactly and the thing is that they
mostly do it for money that's why right
it makes sense it makes it they're
removing the financial incentive because
there are parasitic claim farms that are
running rampant that are literally
existing for the sole purpose of getting
free money and they are basically trying
to put these guys out of business
right right right because if they wanted
to be vindictive they could just start
blocking videos but there's no there's
no what's that - no it's so damn they're
just way
Sting's men power and they get no money
there's no reason for them to go there
it's pretty clever move yeah it makes
sense yeah yeah I was very impressed for
the longest time the incentives have
been all out of whack there's never been
there's never been any reason for these
claimers to not claim everything because
there's no consequence to that mm-hmm so
they had a problem of incentive and this
was a very great way of addressing it so
let's give it up very smart very bold
and they use emojis we like that they're
communicating right and I do want to say
I feel like I want to take a hundred
percent of credit for all the changes I
really do want to say but I don't even
know if I can't say that but I do write
you know I mean this way you did talk a
lot to the one guy who's doing a lot of
all the good changes are good I mean
this is all I can't even know if I can
say it I don't know what we can say but
there's one guy that we love and yeah it
happens to be Israeli but is a funny guy
that we yell at him a lot and he takes
it yeah he like well he's receptive and
he's actually working really hard within
YouTube to change the structure and do
this is all stuff that we've talked at
great length over the past two years
since I've known him
and but every time we get upset then we
yell at him and he's like okay keep it
coming I'm learning him I want to
understand the issue
yeah and we're like no you don't
understand yeah well one of the big
problems one of the big problems a long
time a while ago was we were talking
about that the main problem here is
there's there's no incentive there's you
we have to remove the incentive mm-hmm
anyway the point of bringing them up is
just in short to say that you all
actually can just thank me personally no
but I do hope that he gets a lot of
I'm sure he is Bakshi I don't know if he
is because on one hand I don't know if
they saw they see it right like he's I
hope they I hope he is he's got to be
the guy works his ass off he's in there
he's the first person ever in YouTube
that to actually listen and implement
and try it he's like I don't think
anyone before him active er actually saw
it from the creator's side you know to
their defense they had a lot I always
had a lot of [ __ ] to deal with and maybe
they're just at the point now where they
can actually start working it from that
angle mm-hmm but you're welcome
everybody and I always thought if this
doesn't work out I'll be happy to take a
senior senior office at you they can
hire me as a consultant so there you go
on the other hand YouTube's being sued
by lgbtq+ plus today carry everyone
lesbian gay bisexual trans what's the Q
again queer no it's not queer yes it is
gay is gay is queer
no no queer as queer what's everything
gay and queer Dan oh and queer queer is
more of a I guess you could say a
catch-all for you know it I think you
guys are wrong no no not did I think you
I think it's not where it is queer okay
hold on I'm looking it up did I okay
what do you think it is then questioning
it stands for questioning their sexual
identity it's not queer bro queer why
would it be weird really queer just
means gay and also it's kind of a slur
hue stands for questioning bro more
nuanced than that but maybe maybe I'm
wrong maybe the key was questioning I
we're questioning all right
they got like a whole spectrum I didn't
why is going why do you think that it
says hold on and I recognized inclusion
of popular variant ads letter Q for
those who identify as queer or are
questioning so it sounds like both oh
it's I don't think where is a bad word
there's like that show great where I
something is I guess when I grew up
queer was kind of a slur it can be used
as a slurs but it means weird it means
different basically unusual Wow weird
strange odd but I you you taught me
something I didn't know the question was
was part of it so there you go see that
damn I have some credibility yeah I
don't I haven't lost all my credibility
I almost lost it on the fish cannon LGBT
LGBT we'll wait where's the Q the Q is
not even here well it's a relatively
recent it used to just be LGBT Q came
later see I've seen some variants that
add like several more letters as well
it's getting a little long okay it's
officially you know Jimmy take you plus
but that's the one I most commonly hang
on queer just means gay so Q has to mean
questioning
there's no it doesn't it's not a useful
an amendment a queer you know
interesting and queer okay what does it
mean more than gay it's it's sort of
again it's sort of an umbrella term a
lot of things asexual and sexual oh you
know like it's just kind of like hard to
define I guess yes clearly he's a bit
queer that's what you say back in the
day like he's odd he's an odd one he's a
bit queer right that's where I
originally came he's a little bit uh I
think we should bring him back I don't
think it needs to be like a bad word I
like it here yeah well like you said you
know it's it's been embraces shows that
you know self-identify
but notice folk I mean I don't know
queer seems synonymous with gay like
queer I you're talking about bunch of
gay dudes
in that case yes I think the DI and here
is that it's the more like undefined
kind of right we need to get some LGBTQ
T's on lgbtq+ and then the plus is just
anyone else right
yes which seems quite broad because that
is me no oh so it doesn't include
everyone else
what's the plus well everybody everybody
that is this spectrum of sexuality and
gender so right everybody so why don't
they just shorten it to plus well they
do again I I see a lot of variance on it
sometimes they also include I which is
for intersex I believe so I don't think
there's no there's no there's no council
there's no board
there's no boards these there's no board
of Rex yeah exactly
okay LGBTQI plus hello g b TQ oh and
then maybe there is a nice sometimes
plus sometimes okay i just like with the
more i like the more it's funnier the
more so LGBTQI plus i'm surprised i can
say that LGBTQ y+ l GD b qy plus LGBTQI
plus LGBTQIA
this one says yeah i think the a is
asexual well didn't we get that in the
plus i mean guys don't be greedy you got
the plot right all right where was i
LGBTQI plus are suing youtube they are
suing youtube for being discriminatory I
guess the LGBTQ I floss I can really
good at saying that you want to see this
here they made an announcement video
they all we they made a huge
collaborative announcement video where
well let them explain it better than I
could yeah but they filed a lawsuit
against YouTube officially l GD P qi+
knocks Google and YouTube's treatment of
our lgbtq+ community
oh she know I oh she didn't that's
[ __ ] soda sclusively how the [ __ ]
could she not say I do you know what
sucks Google and YouTube's treatment of
our lgbtq+ community how do you plus
they flagged our pride they did not
allow us to buy ads they restricted us
they demonetised us and they did not
stand up for us and they broke their
promise of a platform for free speech
built off then they blatantly
discriminate against us admit that their
algorithm is biased and promised to fix
it
they lie and still they claim inclusion
I'm gonna go back I won't
with it they blatantly discriminate
against us admit that their algorithm is
bias and promise to fix it they lie and
still they claim inclusion and even what
a march in our parades hi We're brie and
Chrissy from YouTube and this is why we
are suing Google in YouTube
our LGBTQ plus content is being
demonetized
restricted and not sent out to viewers
which has highly affected our ability to
reach the community that we strongly
want to help hi my name is chase Ross
with uppercase chase one on YouTube and
the reason why I'm suing Google and
YouTube is because I'm fed up of the
discrimination that we're getting in the
LGBTQ community YouTube is supposed to
be a safe space for us I don't feel safe
at all things need to change the
algorithm needs to change we need to
stand together because we're more
powerful numbers and honestly standing
here watching our videos get demonetized
it's disheartening it hurts and it needs
to end right now so kid stuff on YouTube
I'm soon so I'm just thinking coming off
of our last episode everything no matter
what we talked about got do monetized
and what you're writing and what
whatever you want and I got it all so
I'm just thinking
I don't know if they're aware but it's
happening right now on everything yeah
that my first thought was that well I
certainly see it from their perspective
of like yeah I'm sure I am sure that
like if you type in your if you type in
your title like gay or trans or
something like that that YouTube will
consider it like they'd be like oh yeah
brands don't want to be associated with
controversial issues yeah why should
this video contractors I don't know why
it should be a controversial issue right
but again I'm not I would need to see
specific details because I saw a clip
that they showed and it showed the two
gay girls making out and they're like
this was demolish and I'm like well you
yea thou mean so in that case I see why
they would do that well if it was a
straight couple making out it is likely
also yeah I mean I'm pretty I'm like
tuned in about feel like I always kind
of have a spicy sense about what would
be democra night if I did kissing I
would not I would expect to yell oh
they're just it's gotten so bad I mean
our last episode just our live with
people got creamed it got a all of our
highlights like it got a really severe
rating just because of the title because
it has I can't even say his name
yeah but but even the tumblr
conversation yeah
it's really bad now when they when there
are they mistaking are they mistaking an
increase in demonization as
discrimination that's my question and it
seems like it seems like probably yes
because YouTube is pretty LGBTQ I was
friendly that's yeah exactly
then what happened like reason to
discriminate seeing what they care about
they always make it very clear that
they're very very put out Pro and
supportive so and then another thing
they have to understand is that again
and this was something I always argue
with
about two is that it's not YouTube I
mean so they're talking about freedom of
speech and stuff like that and well
let's talk about D monetization I mean
that's not to do with YouTube those are
the brands now that now the systems that
YouTube gives the brands is very obtuse
and the pre-check settings for like the
standard really disc ludes a lot of
content that I think should be included
but again YouTube being on the on this
on the safe side history yeah it's all
ever since then and pocalypse yeah so
you know we all Google and all of us got
a hard lesson and a difficult wake-up
call now when you go to the algorithm
issue I think they do have a point and
that's something that I'm grappling with
YouTube too is like so for example our
last podcast if you they go well it's
not appropriate for ads I say okay fine
I don't even care about the ads it's
yellow what I want to make sure is that
my audience is getting the same exposure
to that content the same opportunity to
watch it as all my other ones because
there are certain ratings they like you
can get and YouTube has said this
publicly that you can get on a video
that can suppress its views and by
suppress I mean by like how
age-appropriate it is right depending on
like the sensitivity of content that's
in it right and when it's suppressed
it's that you don't get a notification
when it goes not that no it's not that
it's stuff like showing up on your
homepage because they think oh if it
shows up on your homepage we want it to
be age-appropriate that's a huge one it
might even be less recommendations on
the sidebar now those drive la traffic
and so not and so let's say if you've
signed up and you've said your see I
don't know like I haven't even seen our
new episode on my home page so I don't
even know but yet they want your home
page to be
somewhat friendly so so in the case of a
new podcast we're seeing way less
homepage and recommended hits so the
same thing may well be happening to them
no it really is should be taken on a
video by video basis because I find it
hard to believe that that there's any
you know direct direct attempt to censor
or suppress I think the problem is like
from their point of view I can see that
they've what they feel and they probably
feel like they have a case you know
because there you can just tag a and
then it's demonetised
which is insane and there are
marginalized groups so they looking at
it through that yes but I think they
need to remove the it's like they're
adding bad intention specifically
towards them which I really don't think
is there on the YouTube side I don't
think anyone is targeting them as
there's no I feel like there's no way no
way let's finish washing cuz queer kids
stuff here is about to pitch pitch his
reason why he's suing Google in YouTube
because from day one as an lgbtq+
creator on YouTube I face discrimination
on a platform that touts its support of
my community for years it's affected my
mental health and my livelihood
I've suffered and I've watched and she's
complaining about comments I mean how is
she being a she's saying that her
experience on YouTube is affecting her
yeah I think
from what I was reading about the
lawsuit you know the data on cessation
thing is the big headline thing but it
it's also comes down to like harassing
comments and an inability to from what I
understand and you know this better than
me but you know there suggested thing is
to just turn off the comments but
turning off comments also suppresses you
and the algorithm because the engagement
is part of what that's incorrect that is
incorrect that is a misunderstanding
okay
well I mean that I'm it was my
understanding of what you mean actually
I think they may have put that in the
complaint but that is and as they'll
find quickly as YouTube absolutely
destroys this case is that comment a
comments you will have timings
absolutely no tribe has no signals at
all so all those people that are always
like comment down below to help get this
video you know I think at one point that
may have been true a long time ago but
even then there was no proof ever that
it does anything and I mean well look
PewDiePie for a long time had his
comments disabled entirely and his views
you can look even look backward one did
there was no there was no drop-off in
any way but I mean I've but there that
there's no correlation there and I think
that the blocking the blacklisting tools
are quite robust to but when it comes to
how this stuff affects you and mental
health and all that that I mean we all
go through that it's not specific to
anyone as a group you know it's just
that is just being on the internet being
on YouTube looking at comment section
anywhere right it whatever Twitter I'm
just I'm not really sure what what to
say because she's saying that she's on a
platform that's supposed to protect them
but you're on a public platform that by
its definition I mean we all know what
YouTube is you know not really sure what
you want done you know has suffered I
mean I hate to say I hate to sound like
obtuse but I think the answers you're
looking for probably within yourself I
mean YouTube can't make you more
resilient you you have to make yourself
more resilient from one of the Articles
that the specific aside from monetary
compensation because they are suing for
money and it's one of the things but
it's very number by the way no no I
looked around to try and see how much
they're suing for it and I guess that
would probably be awarded by the court
in some way well they're both rageous I
saw claim of loss of monetary damages is
that one of them
they earn 3500 a month and now they
earned four to five hundred so I mean in
terms of damages I'm not really sure
that you can even I mean that's a
significant drop-off yeah I know but if
I wonder do you sided with the
apocalypse where everybody's money drop
to that degree you know I know you guys
your ad revenue went way down after all
we are at Red Avenue our ad revenue
dropped like literally 90 percent like
for every dollar we were making 10 cents
so the other thing was that they want an
injunction to stop YouTube from quote
censoring restricting restraining or
regulating speech based on
discriminatory or discretionary use or
application of discriminatory animus
based arbitrary well vague unspecified
or subjective criteria which i think
relates to the fact that they're saying
that big LGBT creators seem to be exempt
from a lot of these problems all right
right right that was their main right
let me finish watching the video cuz I
think sure right there another one of
their main points is that creators are
unfairly unevenly treated for a long
time I wondered why YouTube allows this
to happen it's simple they don't care
they usually feed their bottom line and
they simply just don't care about us
they don't care about the importance of
our work they don't care about our
mental health
I mean don't care about our I mean they
care about you as much as they care
about everyone else which is really not
that much because there's like a
trillion people on YouTube alright I got
anyway I gotta stop bagging process it's
high time that we call their blood it's
time they pay for the damage they've
done hi I'm Ann Sommers from what's the
safe word on YouTube and this is why I'm
soon google growing up I was in a very
religious household I didn't get any
sort of gay education let alone queer
education that applied to me and the sex
that I was going to have I create
content on the internet that I wish I
would have had growing up but we're
finding it harder and harder to create
content on this
form Google and YouTube continue to
censor us and tell us that we're not
breaking any rules but that our content
is still not allowed and going to be
restricted on this platform hi I'm Sal
Sidhu Lang and also in steel we're
co-hosts of San Francisco's
glitter-bombed tv.com and we're longtime
creators on YouTube we are suing Google
and YouTube because of blatant
discrimination against us as part of the
lgbtq+ community and they refuse us
advertising because of the gay thing I
don't think they said that LGBT
plaintiff in it I think that it was
against Google and YouTube we are not
going to stand by any longer while our
community gets dismissed belittled and
discriminated against you can help by
sharing our video and our message we're
using the hash gbt Q versus Google
YouTube hash tag don't be evil
hash tag be equal or you can join the
fight with us for more information about
our case our they bore if you'll never
make the part well anyway they got in
the video here they say they alleged
that higher profile creators get special
treatment they cite James Charles
specifically in the complaint though
they emphasize they don't blame Charles
they blame YouTube for playing the roles
unevenly they show a video of him I
think we watched it of him at Coachella
where he's wearing like remember that
alpha D was wearing where his ass is
totally exposed and speaking a woman's
bare butt at Coachella no I don't know
why you think that video wasn't be
monetized because I think there's a big
chance that video was yellowed you know
what I mean yeah a lot of the times my
videos are yellow and other people
ewdiepie and all these huge craters
their videos yellow right and you don't
really you can't assume that it's green
so these guys help with things and a lot
of complained and a lot of stuff I think
that YouTube can easily dispute yeah
by controlling an estimated 95 percent
of the public video communication that
occurs in the world Google and YouTube
wield unparalleled power and unfettered
discretion to apply viewpoint-based
content policies in a way that permits
them to pick winners and losers well
that's true
that's all that's a whole anti-monopoly
law I mean
what is it well they're saying they they
they control 95% of the public video
consumption that occurs around the world
I mean sure I'm not gonna argue with
that as definitely you know it's really
interesting too because I mean that
whole point that they're making you hear
all the time from conservative youtubers
as well you know on the other end of the
spectrum saying that they're being
discriminated against because of their
viewpoints that's the truth right well I
think I think ultimately they're all
mistaking common look like what's what's
the common reality for every youtuber as
discrimination or their group yeah
there's a there's a left-leaning
youtuber that I that I know of PAC David
Pakman and there's not a lot of
left-leaning I don't know I guess
there's the Turkish guys whatever the
Young Turks but this but this guy is
just a lone operation just one dude and
he all the time was getting [ __ ] his
channel was yellow on monetized he was
complaining all the time about it so I
mean I just don't think that there's any
I think that's just a a fallacy
everyone's getting [ __ ] Washington
Post reporter earlier this month that
moderators for YouTube are trained to
treat the most popular video producers
definitely than others by for instance
allowing hate speech to remain on the
site no way while enforcing their
policies more stream stringently against
creators with fewer followers YouTube
denies this claim I'll clarify this the
real truth is they don't apply the rules
differently
it's just that big creators like myself
have direct communication with people at
YouTube so instead of a machine making a
distinction because they have a trillion
videos uploaded every day a human can
make the distinction and make more
nuanced decisions for you and that makes
sense look if you have if you're getting
500 views of video god bless you but
YouTube does not have the resources to
to be involved in with that many people
yeah I mean
that's why they have these powerful
algorithms there's only possible way
that YouTube could exist and the way it
does and so someone like me I can say
hey you know take a look at this video
and they can make that nuanced decision
that a machine can't mm-hmm but it makes
sense I mean come on who you get it
right
I mean that makes sense I mean even us
we went on for most of our time on
YouTube with no any contact there did
that was like a recent development yeah
yeah pretty much until we met this guy
we were talking about two years ago when
we're at creator summit mm-hmm up until
then we didn't have anyone yeah you know
knowing YouTube and everyone that we've
met there they definitely don't have
very intentions
no way it's there's no way in addition
to monetary conversation the lawsuit is
also asking the court to order an
injunction that would stop YouTube from
censoring restriction restraining or
regulating speech based on the
discretionary use or application of
discretionary animus based arbitrary
capricious vague unspecified our
subjective criteria rules go what the
[ __ ] on one hand they want YouTube to
protect free speech and on the other
hand they're upset that YouTube is not
doing anything about hateful speech but
it's like how are you gonna exactly
decide what's hateful speech and expect
them to take it down so easily when you
know things are really hard to define
they expect perfection it's like dude
there's like there's so much comment and
there's so much videos and there's so
many people on YouTube it's just a wild
feral place that's why they have these
powerful algorithms to try to make it
more civilized but hello I mean see
youtube it's the Wild West you know [ __ ]
but I'm just yeah I mean it's
interesting that they're actually suing
you two but I'm fairly certain that
YouTube is gonna really watch you bro
yeah even if they did have a more strong
case I think their case is
extraordinarily weak now I'm not saying
I disagree with their point of view and
that I don't sympathize with that right
I'm just saying from a legal standpoint
their case is like air and you're going
against one of the most powerful
organizations that has ever existed that
have lawyers falling out of their
[ __ ] pockets you know I mean yeah
that's a it's a big enemy to take on
yeah but it's interesting right but I
think you know I think the only thing
out of all of this that you know if it
is true I could see them having a point
and would hope that YouTube would do
something about it is if they're really
just blanket getting demonetised for
just having a tag like gay in the video
or the title I mean that that is that's
over the top I'm like you know if it
really is happening instantly like you
you upload a video you put that in the
tag and just immediately be monetized
right I agree that that's a difficult
situation
yeah I'm sure YouTube has already looked
into that because I know that there's
been a lot of complaints about I mean
mmm
gay just the word gay yeah I could see
that getting going yellow if I'd made it
if I said and if I made a video and now
and I said I'm coming out as gay or
whatever I would be concerned with my
spidey sense and I'm pretty accurate
that that would go yellow so that is a
problem you know but how so but yeah
it's mean it's so this happens a lot by
the way when I say Jew or Israel or
anything like that it goes yellow isn't
that [ __ ] up like all of my old videos
that say Jew or anything like that
yellow because they see it they were
viewing it
isn't that funny Joo is considered any
conversation around you consider you
know how did they call it since
sensitive well it's and it's probably
because of the algorithm right because
they've detected lots of you know
anti-semitic videos yeah and I mean use
that term exactly I know or they like
they don't they also don't monetize
religious stuff anything has to do with
religion right right so it's like whammy
whammy bammy but if you make a video
said I'm coming out as gay I don't know
my boyfriend is gay something's gay I
would say 50/50 on that you can dispute
though on a pretty strong dispute
problem with the dispute process is by
the time it gets resolved most of all of
your views most of your monetized views
have already come and gone but it's just
you know it's really tough because say I
mean how how does the algorithm supposed
to know the difference between someone
who's using it in a derogatory way and
then then then they're making a video
about derogatory about gay people and
then advertisers find out that their ads
were on that video
that's right on one hand they're
complaining about freedom of speech and
on the other about hate speech being not
removed well let me add is the problem
let me clarify your argument there's an
absolutely no free speech issue at hand
here their videos are allowed up right
they are not removed they are not age
restricted as far as I can tell their
free speech is not being impeded in any
way being able to monetize that's a
different story
there is an argument to be made though
about like removing the incentive to
monetize it could discourage certain
kinds of speech you know but I don't
know it's a tough situation you know I
don't know I mean I underst
and I understand their their their anger
but I don't know you know I mean
ultimately sometimes it's really just
you know don't be evil be equal I'll be
LGBTQ versus Google YouTube what they do
Google YouTube they made that
unnecessarily long LG LGBTQ versus
YouTube while Google YouTube thinks they
just want to get as many people worried
as they can type we got more we got more
TV guy you see this is a weird one man
with TV on his head going around leaving
old television on porches over 60 TVs so
far now many people have heard say that
they think this is kind of charming or
he's not harming anyone I personally
think it's one of the creepiest things I
ever seen you are in fact seeing a
person with the TV set on their head
laying an older set on someone's front
porch and just walking off he wants to
be known as the TV Santa Claus I don't
know the bizarre discovery happened
Sunday morning in Reich OHS Hampshire
neighborhood like TV Freddy Krueger it
150 homes we got an old tube style TV
13-inch I thought my son brought it home
but apparently not
they had way too much time on their
hands if they had all these TVs and
spread them out over you know all over
the neighborhood
I love this they're doing multiple
neighbors but think it's only a prank
targeting no one in particular I think
even Martha's murder inconvenience to
the community
officers and county workers spent Sunday
morning picking up the old units the
hauling the mission is being some parts
too
I think history played out in Glennallen
the same thing happened in a different
neighborhood last August timing that's
not lost on some thing it's just a prank
some college students who were just
bored back to school maybe TV man was he
was just ready to strike to put a little
humor into our lives in the absence of
knowing the brains inside the box I
don't know that's what is he trying to
prove these homeowners get up stay away
from the screens I don't know why do
people do anything people are weird bro
it's all fun and games until these
people start showing up dead you know
how they're gonna die he's gonna smash
their head into the TV and then they're
gonna find their body on the bed or
something with the TV on their head
dressed like him and he's gonna dress
him in the same suit and [ __ ] you're
watching too many movies I'm telling you
dude that shit's real I just watched the
documentary about who's that guy that
they just caught yeah man that's
something he would do I'm telling you I
got more footage of this guy I'm not
kidding around TV had strikes again
shit's frightening I don't find it scary
really watch this one the idea of anyone
approaching my house at night is like
well I find it more spooky if it's just
like I let spooky if he has a TV on his
head dude your ring goes off at 2:00
a.m. and you see this yeah that's very
creepy
then he waves by the way Oh God yeah
that guy's coming to put your head in
one of those TVs guarantee it how do you
guys feel about that it's just it's
creepy like isn't that TV heavy on his
head it's hollowed out it's just it's
just my god it looks really anyway Oh
hardly terrifying there you go mm-hmm
what's going on back there can hear
talking yeah package
yes package just arrived sorry oh so
that's TV guy you know it's all fun and
games until head start and then up in TV
screens that Golden State killer one was
[ __ ] crazy man oh my god
where was that on Netflix or I think so
so the Golden State killer this first of
all that the Netflix doctrine is really
good this guy was one of the most
prolific criminals in the United States
history and then the the best part is
that a couple years ago this guy went
uncaught after like 50 years meeting so
many heinous crimes I mean the worst
crimes you can imagine don't say it
because we'll get to mom ties
he stops 50 really bad things YouTube
sends me a report back they go oh you
mentioned this at this minute and a
two-hour long podcast so age-restricted
yeah but they caught him because they
had his DNA sample and then somebody put
it in like ancestry.com match DNA to
some distant cousin and then from that
that was the only lead they ever had on
him and the technology just caught up
with this guy and then they started
questioning the family and closing in
and once they found out this guy's like
third cousin or whatever then they
eventually found the guy he was an
ex-cop cuz the whole time this guy was
evading arrest and they're like they
started to think as this guy a cop is he
military how does he know he was an
ex-cop and he had a wife and kids right
he had a wife and Dawn and two daughters
and he was like his victims were all
females it's so much like Dexter yeah
you know it's amazing
they certainly modeled that show after
all these cases when they wrote that
care mm-hmm but man that was a good show
what was that documentary called
something about the Golden State Killer
fascinating stuff and I think then they
caught him like a year after the
documentary came out yeah yeah I in part
because of the documentary probably
renewed interesting anyway that's TV guy
on his head so watch out
well hopefully this didn't happen
anywhere near me cuz that guy's just a
moment away from killing people it's the
Golden State killer it's not over that's
what it's called hmm I wanted your guys
take on this Chris
como como on CNN he's an anchor on CNN
Cuomo kuhmo someone someone went up to
him I called him Fredo which is the
[ __ ] brother from Godfather's that goes
against the family and is assassinated
okay and so he's an Italian man and
people and and so people that don't like
him
conservatives usually call
Fredo as an insult well this one person
did in a video that people yes well
that's the story he says in the video
too that's why he's so touchy about it
that was calm Fredo according to him I
mean it's it's duh it's not he's he's
afraid of people call him Fredo well
anyway he's at dinner with his uh that
dinner with his family his children's
wife and here is the conference
confrontation and I'm curious what you
guys think about about his reaction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take your [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
okay well let's break this down first of
all the context is important because his
friend is secretly recording the
altercation he kind of bitched out when
he got called out because he's like I
thought it was your name meanwhile his
friend is secretly recording him because
he knew they knew that they were getting
the jump out of him okay
do you think Fredo is an ethnic slur
for Italian that's kind of a fun on the
level of the n-word yeah no no imagine
imagine you're the bar of racial
injustice is from the Godfather it's
from a movie about Italian gangsters and
even if you're using it as to disparage
somebody it's not like an ethnic thing
you know it's like it's about what that
character is in the context of the story
I guess yeah well I guess he's Italian
and right he took it there but right
exactly
oh you'll have a problem aisle three so
I don't know what do you think cuz
there's been people on both sides people
are saying como has tweeted previously
that fro Fredo was an ethnic slur last
year and when someone called him Fredo
this is let's see this is from I just
don't get his reaction seems very he's
very touchy about it
I mean it seems pretty unstable for he
goes for someone who's on the TV every
day but you gotta be prepared for people
coming at you oh it's stupid
whatever good point imagine from his
imagine from his perspective it's on a
daily basis he's out with his family
he's signing hey Fredo okay good point I
mean that's a fair point he's on the
news every day there's a very fair point
hey Fredo just I don't see I think what
would have been better he needs to think
of a really silly like retort you know
hey Fredo
hey i'ma throw you down a [ __ ] flight
of stairs Jamie that's what gets me to
is it's like he's upset about it Italian
stereotype so he starts a very Oh
typical like [ __ ] Jersey Italian dude
possible it's funny cuz I've seen that
guy show he doesn't sound like that you
wanna go to the flight down the stairs
look turned into Ethan Bradberry all of
a sudden but anyway he last year said no
some said okay we noticed when Fredo
gets testy they said that to him no
reason to use bigoted references to be
critical I can be wrong stupid lots of
prerogative designations but I take that
as an Italian slurp because it is it's
from the [ __ ] Godfather that makes
you a bigoted full here's a roll don't
be a bigot try to follow it I don't know
about that man it's the Godfather I
think the Godfather is a far cry from
from hundreds of years of slavery I
think it's kind of applause that's a
good thing - yeah come on the n-word
it's it's not a comparable dude please
it's from the movie I just surprised
that his reaction so not classy Jesus
yo surprised - I think you're I think
you're right he's got a holy [ __ ]
together
he apologized but you know what
surprised me people on the on the right
side were were defending him for example
let's see here it didn't even like Sean
Sean Hannity yeah said oh here it is
dude everything's a Twitter link
everything happens on Twitter these days
it's unbelievable I say good for Chris
Sean Hannity said he's out with this
nine year old daughter his wife and the
guys being a jackass in front of his
family in my field this is how you'll be
able to show example for your daughter I
think the way you act is you walk away
exactly you let the guy be a douche and
you walk away I certainly wouldn't want
to get that excited in front of my
family in my opinion Chris has zero to
apologize for he deserves the apology
I think the best way to be like dude
have some respect I'm here with my
family
exactly you know you're humiliated the
guy it's like dude I'm here with my
family have some respect that's it and
then you make the other person look
stupid and feel bad totally
instead you puff out your chest and
threatened to throw him down the stairs
it's just it just makes everybody in
that video seem like an idiot I'm finish
on Hannity's the defensive him that was
surprising to be frank you know what
let's read his apology and then Trump of
course weighed in which we must address
appreciate all the support is what truth
is I should be better than the guys
baiting me this happens all the time
these days often in front of my family
but there's a lesson no need to add to
the ugliness I should be better than
what I post that's a good apology yeah
that's fair I think that's a great I
think that is as good of apology as one
can make actually you know Fredo
you're afraid you you solidified
yourself as Fredo forever and that right
with that reaction but now everybody
like Trump is calling him Fredo now
there's Trump sweet I thought this was
interesting because he said I thought
Chris was Fredo also the truth hurts
totally lost it low rating CNN but then
he goes he goes what Chris kimono be
given a red flag come on
I don't know the [ __ ] he's how do you
say that Cuomo Cuomo he's got this
Italian [ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about what is he talking
about red flag is that a thing because I
saw it people are this about yeah the
red flag was a weapon yeah about gun
restrictions okay okay so he says uh
filthy language in a total loss control
he shouldn't be allowed to have any
weapons he's not so I was like oh my god
is this Trump supporting gun control
well after the incident a couple weeks
ago he seems more open to it
hmm I don't know if that's ever gonna go
anywhere but
well there you have it he supports gun
control only in the specific case of
Chris kimono Cuomo Cuomo mm-hmm so there
you have it
Fredo is a racial slur the [ __ ] man and
you know hilarious yeah I know about the
much frayed up to us like love him or
hate him his politics you you got a
credit him his Twitter game his Twitter
insult game is pretty hilarious that's
why he's president no become being a
bomb ass tweeter actually can get you to
be President and these things he doesn't
know anything about policy yes but have
you seen his tweets they're bomb you
know trying to make a joke about how
like a Jewish character is a slur
there's already so many Jewish slurs
though I don't need to make those up hmm
what is a good Jewish character that
could be like comparable to it's afraid
oh yeah that's the ethnic slur Costanza
Costanza yeah
don't hate Constanza is a Jewish slur
guys watch ela watch this you're veget
vegetables or e nted so what do you
think about Arby's they said hey lo they
can make meat from veggies then we can
make veggies from meat introducing the
merit and of course it's Arby's the most
disgusting filth ridden meat factory on
the planet you're gonna want to eat this
you like guarantee it what a sound
turn it off cuz oh good good looks like
a carrot oh my god what is this yeah
yeah doesn't that look just like a yeah
oh here we go [ __ ] her up you look great
why would you want that see that's why
why would they go through all this
I'm assuming it's a joke but write down
I mean I think they're they're making a
pushback against how all these fast food
restaurants are getting the beyond meat
but this is America what's your problem
because it's Arby's they're all about
the meat but that's not a real product I
hope not
that's nothing that look not awful but
then when you cut it open it just looks
like a hot dog you know oh my god so
leave it we have the man-made balls yeah
the problem is that is that it's still
meat do it's not healthier all these
brands think they have a sense of humor
you know it's the worst isn't it [ __ ]
hate them I will I will pledge to you
right now that I will never eat at
Arby's or take anyone I know the RV's
for any reason whatsoever I this is my
pledge to you after watching that merit
video I would eat it
Zack you really need to get your [ __ ]
brain checked bro you would eat that oh
yeah I would try it what is that they're
going again against veggie burgers
really you got nothing else to worry
about right a lot of people you know
because the the beyond burgers they
downloaded this Dan gonna be like
intrigued to try though no let's dude I
know that tastes like [ __ ] bro come on
it's it's and it was seasoned in karat
flakes on top of it like can you imagine
a worse flavor for chicken crimes no it
yeah no I I'll show you it was a it was
like carrot flakes it yeah yeah this
dried carrot juice powder yeah you're
right that's you know I'm stupid
but the thing so the thing is why it
doesn't make any sense and I don't even
know why I'm arguing because I think it
obviously doesn't make sense but you
have a hamburger which is a delicious
thing that people want to enjoy but
people don't eat it because it has meat
and they object to eating meat for
various reasons now the problem with
this is that these same people Kenny
everyone can already eat a carrot yeah
we're already can eat a carrot and the
people that are vegetarians are not
going to eat this carrot no one is
eating does it or not except that it's
actually me there's literally no target
demographic for this meat carrot the
burger makes sense people want the
burger yeah I think that they're just
trying they're trying to stake
themselves out as you know a meat
defender so to speak they feel they feel
accosted by all these beyond burgers
showing up that I think it's viral
marketing and I think they're winning
except we could just show it here's the
problem with viral marketing at least in
this case they haven't given me any
interessant going to the restaurant I
mean dude is this what you want - is
this what you want to invoke when I
think Arby's you want me to think about
this [ __ ] I mean dude they can't
even make Arby's look good in the
commercials bro they have these
newcomers yeah oh my they go we have the
meats a new bread with Hawaiian bread
and it's literally looks just a
disgusting cut of lunch meat its
disgusting they can't make it look good
yeah to have this commercial that I see
all the time and I'm just like this
doesn't look good well someone's going
on RVs Zach who is going RVs that we're
right here dude what do you get from
Arby's Zach uh double beef and cheddar a
little horsey sauce
excuse me horsey sauce for semen it's
like a horseradish Oh horse right do
they make you say horsey sauce yeah it's
called horsey sauce I can't believe RVs
is still in business after you do what
do you watch a lot simpsons right cuz
that cuz in the early era of The
Simpsons the RV's was like their go-to
to [ __ ] on their own oh no they used to
just [ __ ] make out Arby's to be so
disgusting all the time as a running
joke I remember that yeah and I mean
that even when I was growing up I ate
meat and I never want to go to her
because it's just like I think it's my
mind was poisoned by all these roses on
The Simpsons and all of Ventura growing
up a town of 200 thousand people there
was one Arby's that sat so pathetic and
lonely and it was always there it always
hung through but you always expected to
close it's still open to this day and I
just don't know how Arby's has continued
to claw its way yeah and to the high
school I went to had an Arby's across
the street as well as a Taco Bell and
without fail the Arby's I'd never saw
yeah and these are like hungry as high
school students you can talk about was
packed all the time I think I hate to
say this but I think Arby's was reserved
for them only the most white trash
people on the planet like you like you
have to be the whitest trash ever Thanks
where you take a bite of this are my
batch Zach I don't know what you are bro
but you have to look at this sandwich
let me pull up an image for you guys
Arby's new sandwich and this has to look
like a gourmet sandwich for you okay
this is the fruit over the scooter Anish
might be actually so these actually this
isn't the ones they show on the
commercial the one they show on the
commercials is just like literally meat
and bread here these look at this
it's it's just it's just meat bread and
a slice of cheese meat like they can't
even make it look good
I've seen there's a worst-looking
commercial right now I've seen something
that looks worse well here this is their
classic I mean look at this a more
pathetic looking sandwich oh well look
at this sila for the hungry looks like a
baloney
I mean you have to be swiped trash down
to the bone you have to be drunk maybe
that's it maybe they're kept afloat by
that's not enough they have primetime
commercials dude I can't get enough for
this looks like have you ever tried one
yes Zach it's been a long time though
give it another shot
I already pledged never to I mean I know
okay here here's a real picture of what
[Laughter]
yeah here I mean that's real that's what
it looks like right Zach yeah yeah
that's not it that's not it
yeah MEAP flaps baby I mean this is what
it is usually RVs - shut up they need to
be happy that they got business you got
to look at this and don't push it
were you looking I'm trying to find the
ones that I see on TV all the time I
don't want you to reference this yeah
this is them trying to make it look good
me just go to a deli if you want a roast
beef sandwich that bad you know
absolutely it's way better options
anyway so everyone's right now so
finally did you find it Eli do you want
to keep looking no it's fine yeah you
get that yeah it's just like there's one
that's like super saucy
and it's just like this saucy meat and
bread on top and bottom Arby's saucy
looks awful sandwich looks like
radioactive like the color of it is like
neon orange I don't call that like this
no no neon orange I'll take a picture
when it's on TV next I see a lot of
Arby's commercials lately man those guys
are so pushing harlots yeah look at this
look at this [ __ ] thing dude Oh Zach
would you eat this probably not no you
wouldn't eat that look look how they
prepared it does that look good that you
know what I need it yeah I mean really
yeah mmm oh the head that it's just the
healthy beef and cheddar that's probably
what you're looking for me no beef it's
gotta be beef like some sausage like a
buffalo kinda thing
oh no it's like covered with sauce okay
Buffalo good look I can't get over these
real visitors you cannot make that look
good I just can't believe that they have
the shout-out to uh they gotta go
against companies are making a
vegetarian option what's your problem
yeah don't piss heel off with that [ __ ]
she'll [ __ ] your whole life up dude
she's gonna find these buffalo cheesy
sandwiches and make you wish you never
made that thing look at this who wants a
bite Zach tell me you would eat that
it's kind of like yeah what's that
little one with sauce it literally looks
rotten kind of like that
to get a commercial buyback look chicken
slider let's look it up hold on buffalo
chicken slider this is different yeah
what the [ __ ] damn well that actually
just for the record this sandwich that
looks decent is not rvs oh I need to
write Arby's that's why idiot dumbass
Ethan okay that's like a cream pie but
they made they clearly like made super
photoshopped it and it's all glossy and
like really shiny I don't think you can
beat this one yeah it's kind of like
this you can't beat that one I wonder
how many people are going to Harvey's
right now just you can find a better
meal man to be fair the marketing
department we're talking about Arby's
for 20 minutes now but it's Blatter I
don't know if this helps I guess
probably all these people who hate
Arby's hate Arby's and people who are
like Arby's are gonna want to yeah going
right now whatever I got my goof self
mr. sitting period blood go enjoy your
used tampon between bread I will yeah
and then finally we're gonna end off on
a high note in has to pee has become a
cherished meme within the h3 community
and somebody made a comic actually got
4000 points so this is a popular stain
goes there in outer space they made it
to like God or something says welcome to
the center of the universe inferior
life-forms you have the right to one
question only and now that astronauts
talk amongst themselves they say well
naturally we should ask about the nature
of life itself in human existence right
I don't know perhaps it's best to ask
about the future what do you think in in
and they turn around and then in has
already wasted the
Jim and God has answered the toilet is
down the hall to the right
I got a piece so bad
very good h3 nation warriors well I had
a lot of fun we have lots of laughs we
had lots of gaffes and goofs Ian are you
holding it I got a piece so yeah yeah
yeah just hold on the show we're about
to end the show right now
Ian you don't have to keep interrupting
me I did we're literally ending the show
I got a piece so it's just roommate tale
I know it's just rude that you keep
interrupting I'm sorry your mics turned
off sorry and I got a very good I want
the record to show that I'm the only one
that hasn't gone to the bathroom today
in this office yeah you're trying to
make a point we got it
I'm really thirsty what do you have so
bad do you have to pee in I got a piece
so bad don't mute his mic no I agree
don't mute his mic don't hear anything
no Ian come back I'm Dan I forgive you
from his mics open he's got the control
see now you ruined oh my god I wanted to
hear from in we'd never get here freedom
of speech then Dan
I am you infringe on his on his freedom
I pledge you that no one will mute your
mic again it's open he could talk what
we use a mic is open but my soul is
closed I got a piece all right well we
better wrap this up dan has to be guys
thank you so much for watching for
coming along for a different place go
watch our previous episode because
apparently you didn't show it to anyone
I
you don't even have to watch it just
leave it on the background just click it
and refresh and
that's it folks but a bit of everything
that's all folks I got a piece so bad
you look quick who was the who who
what was the Emancipation Proclamation
that's correct
about what year was the the Declaration
of Independence signed something like
767 something widows that means 76 am i
right
I better be yeah July 4 1776 let me ask
you how many amendments are in the
Constitution I think it's a 35 27 oh
[ __ ] 27 that's the word that was like
one of the ones I was like nobody knows
that well I know what are the first
tenement first 10 amendments of the
Constitution called Bill of Rights and
what did the Bill of Rights do name
three things the Bill of Rights do you
mean the Constitution no the Bill of
fricking Rights it defines the
government no that's a we have homework
to do we've got a homework there guys
thank you for watching we've got a lot
of studying to do so what does the what
was been asserted that one
oh the Bill of Rights yeah things that
it it ensures like isn't it like freedom
of religion freedom of the press I don't
know that's the question you're mixing
it up let's wrap this up okay quickly
then mixing it all up and it all right
bye everybody see you next week
[Music]
you
[Music]